dorval qui sont ces hommes les
adorateurs de rachat laden ils se
réunissent derrière la montagne puis le
dollar mais du grand roi assad elle va
enfin se remettre en marche alors les
royaumes simon n'auront d'autre choix
que de s'unir et de combattre à nouveau
ensemble
il est temps qu'on nous tous qu'une
nouvelle ère voit le jour celle où le
ring stone mené par la main d'un dieu
dirigera le monde
ne craignez rien torvald qui va rien se
passer et au pire je serai là pour vous
protéger
tu vas vivre ce pourquoi tous nos
ancêtres se sont sacrifiés 120 espèces
de vieux tard et sione debout qu'est ce
qui vous est passé par cette fête
complètement malade
trouvez les airs apporté mois leur tête
je ne donne pas cher de la peau de tous
les habitants du ring stone dans
quelques heures à peine toute la contrée
sera feu et à sang ton père vient de
lancer lamamra lie à la fin des neuf
dimensions
je ne crois pas à vos culs
vous avez étrange jeune humain on
devrait vous faire écorché vif pour vos
propos mais vous gens demandaient encore
oui je pars dans ton sommeil
si on m'avait dit je ferai ça un jour je
n'aurais pas cru